DevOps is a collaborative approach just
taken up by most companies these days
it focuses on scaling up and making the
entire process of scaling up much
smoother so no doubt companies are
actively looking out for DevOps
engineers welcome to another tutorial
with simply learn I'm Angela and today
we'll be looking into how you can become
a DevOps engineer so let's begin so by
definition DevOps is a collaboration
between the development and the
operations team which enables continuous
delivery of application and services to
the end-users so let's expand on this
definition first the development team is
the one that actually produces the
products the operation team is related
with the management or the maintenance
of these products now there's a link
that DevOps forms between these two
teams
which makes this entire process much
smoother and this approach this
collaborative approach is what Kanta
Bob's so DevOps
focuses on continuous delivery of
application which means that when the
development team is ready with the
product it immediately goes into the
maintenance on the management phase and
it's then pushed on to the end users
with minimum delay just in case you
doubt the stand of DevOps today or its
growth in the near future you must know
that according to the information week
devops will be in high demand for
upcoming years and has no chance of
slowing down
also according to Linden over the past
few years the bob says increase in
demand by 50% now that's quite a lot of
growth so clearly DevOps is a field
that'll be great to dive into and grow
in so before we begin how you can
actually become a DevOps engineer let's
look at what we'll be going through in
this video first we look at who is a
DevOps engineer followed by the DevOps
career roadmap will then look into a
DevOps certification and then finally
the salary trends for a divorce engineer
so who is a DevOps engineer now a DevOps
engineer is an IT professional who
understands the software development
lifecycle and when I say software
development life
I do not just mean the DevOps approach
but right from a waterfall model which
is a traditional software development
lifecycle and then as you know we moved
on to the agile and finally we reached
the DevOps lifecycle so a DevOps
engineer needs to understand the whole
purpose of this lifecycle why we had to
move from one model to the other what
are the shortcomings of the previous
models had and what all those DevOps
make up for also other than
understanding this entire process they
also need to know how to use the various
automation tools for developing the
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipelines so of course your
next question must be what is the
continuous integration and continuous
deployment pipeline as you can see on
your right we have an image of this
pipeline so there are various stages so
first you have your planning stage where
you plant things out and write an
algorithm for your product then it's the
building stage where the algorithm
actually transforms into a code and is a
product which could be used then you
have the testing stage in the testing
stage your product is tested all the
bugs are caught and all of this is
corrected and once all of that is done
it's then sent to the deployment stage
which means now your product is ready to
be deployed once it's deployed of course
a product needs continuous monitoring
this is now something new which is being
introduced in the DevOps lifecycle that
although your product is out indie and
the monitoring stage is something that
the DevOps approach focuses on much more
than our previous models and for very
good reason which is that once your
product is deployed into the real world
to ensure customer satisfaction it's
important that you continuously monitor
the product this way you are able to
catch the bugs fix them and push it back
to the client and ensure that they are
happy with your product and would go for
it again now in simple words a DevOps
engineer is expected to collaborate with
the developers and the operations team
to deliver high quality products within
a minimum amount of time now DevOps
engineer as such is not a profile that
you might come across very often but of
course there are a number of career
paths that you can take under the DevOps
engineer but of course there are a
number of career paths under
Bob's engineer some of these are the
DevOps architect automation engineer
software tester integration specialist
security engineer and release manager
now let's look at the DevOps career
roadmap so basically if you are looking
forward to bagging that DevOps engineer
job where should we start and how should
you go about it first thing first there
are a few programming languages which go
hand in hand with the DevOps tools you
need to pick up these and also know the
Linux fundamentals DevOps uses these
programming languages for developing and
automating software now three most
common languages used with the DevOps
tools are Ruby Python and JavaScript it
is always advised that you know at least
one of these of course we must consider
the fact that these three languages are
used with completely different tools so
knowing just one of these languages does
not mean that you can now work with any
tool under the DevOps approach but it
does give you a good hang of at least
one of them which is more than Moore's
can say it's also important to know the
fundamentals of the Linux command line
interface of course this is not very
unique to devups whichever career path
you are choosing Linux fundamentals is
one of the most important things let's
now discuss some of the mandatory Linux
skills that DevOps engineers should be
aware of the first is of course the
linux shell now you must either know
bash or the kernel shell then say Linux
commands now there are a huge number of
Linux commands but the basic ones you
must know no matter what are the find
crap okay and the set command and
finally we have the networking commands
nslookup which is for querying the DNS
and netstat for monitoring your
connections our next milestone would be
learning the source code management now
source code management is especially
important when you're dealing with huge
projects so that all your codes
irrespective of the number of files you
have or the number of versions of a
particular code AHA everything is
organized and can be easily accessible
so it's important that you are
comfortable with at least one of these
source code management tools here the
most common ones we see are gate
EVs and mercurial I would personally
recommend you to choose get and why get
because get is used to track changes in
the source code it can manage large
projects efficiently and it allows
multiple developers to work together
with great ease now our next stage is to
learn to build applications so a DevOps
engineer must know how to build an
application and commit to the source
code management tools such as git now
popular tool use to build applications
which makes things much simpler is maven
why maven well it supports parallel
builds instant access to new features
without any additional configuration and
has easy build process now maven is
actually an automation tool which helps
to build and manage software projects
within a short period of time so here
you have the palme file which is
required to build an application under
which you have sets of jars you have the
commands which are to be executed the
builds plug-ins and the builds profile
but in order to automate the entire
process you require a continuous
integration or a continuous development
tool and this brings us to our fourth
stage which is learning to automate the
process using CI and CD tools one of the
most extensively used tools in this
field is Jenkins Jenkins is an open
source continuous integration tool it
helps to automate continuous development
testing and deployment of newly created
codes
well--why Jenkins because it has
multiple plugins
it is easily distributed across multiple
machines and has an easy installation
and configuration process a next stage
is to learn to test the applications
once you have completed the build
process learn how to automate the
testing process of web applications one
of the best testing tools for QA teams
is selenium and why selenium above all
the other tools that provide the same
functionality well because it provides
fast execution allows scripting in
several languages and also supports
parallel test execution the next thing
is to learn to deploy applications in
production servers so you should learn
how to deploy and run the
patience in the production servers and
in order to deploy an application you
should have the knowledge of containers
such as docker and configuration
management tools like ansible so docker
helps with the containerization while
configuration management tools such as
ansible so docker health its
containerization well while tools such
as ansible helps you to provide you the
capability of pushing configurations
onto multiple servers and maintaining
them in the required state so why choose
token high scalability and efficiency
reusable data volumes isolated
applications and why ansible because
unlike other tools in this field it has
a push base configuration it is
agentless and uses SSH for secure
connections the next stage is to learn
to monitor the applications so
monitoring your applications is another
important aspect of a DevOps engineer in
this stage we identify the issue and
implement the changes as quickly as
possible the most popular tool which
provides for monitoring applications is
nagi O's it has a comprehensive
monitoring system high availability and
immediate remediation and finally the
Box engineer must know the working of
cloud providers for a DevOps engineer
it's important to know about the cloud
service providers and their basics cloud
computing is an important skill to learn
irrespective of which field you're in to
them as a lot of companies have the
infrastructure on the cloud Amazon Web
Services is the most popular cloud
provider whereas Microsoft Azure and
Google cloud platform are slowly
catching up to Amazon Amazon Web
Services provides high scalability and
flexibility is cost effective and
provides better security let's now look
at some of the DevOps certifications you
can opt for the first one is the a
doubly certified DevOps engine your
program which is offered by Amazon Web
Services and then of course we have the
DevOps certification training offered by
our very own simply learn simple on also
provides programs which are more
specific to tools such as chef puppet
ansible and selenium certification and
we also provide a DevOps architect
master's program so now these are some
of the most popular
certifications available in the market
let's get a better idea of what these
certifications provide so we'll move on
to the simple on webpage so here we are
on the landing page for DevOps
certification training course as you can
see here this course provides 56 hours
of in-depth learning you will be working
on more than 10 real industry projects
which are integrated with the labs there
are 24 lite demos of the most popular
DevOps tools you have a 24 by 7 support
dedicated to mentor you throughout your
project and we also provide self-paced
learning so there are videos which are
always available in case you have a very
stringent timetable let's now look at
some of the tools which are covered
under this course so under build
automation we cover maven among other
tools configuration management this
ansible chef puppet continuous
integration and monitoring tools
includes Jenkins steam City docker and
testing frameworks we have a clan j-unit
version control bitbucket git
so we are going through a number of
tools but as you can see all the popular
ones are definitely covered other than
this let's also have a quick look at all
the topics that is covered under this
course so we have the course
introduction followed by introduction to
DevOps and then we focus on the various
processes under there Bob's version
control countries integration deployment
and build tools software automation
testing frameworks configuration
management containerization all of this
is followed up my need of cloud in
DevOps and of course you have practice
projects we also are provided with two
free courses one covering the Linux
basics and one with the fundamentals of
JavaScript since as we have already
mentioned these are two very important
skills that a DevOps engineer must
possess and now this is the DevOps
architect master's program offered by
simply learn this is the go-to program
if you take becoming a DevOps engineer
seriously as you can see your guys it
covers more than 40 in-demand skills and
15 plus tools you have access to 120
life in short to let online classes
you'll also be working on more than two
and real-life projects and at the end of
the entire course you receive your
master certification there's a well
thought out timeline to proceed with
your course which covers instructor-led
and self-paced classes your projects and
your lab sessions also some of the tools
that we'll be covering under this
program include maven chef puppet
ansible saltstack teamcity Jenkins
Nagios Ju net JIT and many more so guys
why procrastinate anymore get on to
simply learn web page register yourself
to a course and get certified get ahead
of course if you are taking up a career
you must know what kind of salary to
expect an average salary of a divorce
engineer in the United States is hundred
and fifteen thousand six hundred and
sixty six dollars per year so this is
the average salary as you can see your
guys as a graph which shows how there's
been a growth this graph here will give
you a good idea of the salary trend an
average salary of a DevOps engineer in
India on the other hand is six lakh
twelve thousand per year so again here
we have a graph on the right which
demonstrates the pattern in growth in
the salary now here's some additional
material to prepare yourself and help
you in the journey to becoming a DevOps
engineer so this is simply launch
YouTube playlist on DevOps as you can
see here are a number of videos to be
precise they have 82 videos or 82
tutorials on DevOps you can start off
with this fun short video on what is
DevOps it introduces DevOps to you in
the most basic and fun way possible and
then you have DevOps tutorial for
beginners what is DevOps another
tutorial introduction to DevOps and then
we can follow this up with the tutorials
on the various tools under DevOps for
example there's get there's Jenkins
Dakka Dakka swarm ansible chef puppet a
comparison between the various
configuration management tools there are
also devups
interview questions part 1 and part 2
which will help you prepare for your
interviews wider bops
is better than agile or if it's the
other way around watch this video to
find out how to create your resume for
the post of a DevOps engineer and so on
so there are a lot of videos here guys
you can definitely go through them
provides you with a lot of information
not only that before you actually take
up the simply learned course to get a
better understanding of the kind of
content and the quality of content that
they offer you can come here and check
out their free courses or the free
tutorial videos and that we come to an
end of this video I hope you all enjoyed
it and I hope it was really helpful for
all those who are aspiring to become a
DevOps engineer please hit the like
button if so also share our video and
subscribe to our channel if you haven't
yet because we have a lot more coming up
for you so thank you and see y'all next
time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here